που την ιστορία δ αφο εμαστε δίπλα κίναι τη θεθέμα όμαρουσί να το βάσειω αφού
υπάρχο όλα είναι αφού υπάρχουν τώρα αν διπλωματικά μπορούμε να απο φύγουμε ότι μπορούμε να
αποφύγουμε ναι όμως ενημοίρα ένυ είμαστε πταμέ και ραμέίο πολέμος εγώ θέλω να από κάτι
ένας πόλεμος δεν είναιυπάτο πριν δεν ένω πατικό θέμα δεν πρέπια παίρνουμε μια στάσει καια
λέμε έτσι πρέαγίνι άλλο πως προά είναι για τα λιπά κιαταλεβά ένας τεθκιασμοςφίς πολεμος καταλαβαίνω
ότι στορικά τον βλέπουμε ότι ναι το ιράνείναι πρόβλημα στη περιοχή το ανάτυξη τη πυρηνικόν
είναι πρόβληα στη πυρια δεν πρέπει να αφεθεί το ιράν λαλό το έτσι αυρο απλά
δεν πρέπει να αφεθεί το ιρά ως φντεμθαλιστικό κράτος αντμαθαιστική δύεναμη στην περιοχή να αναπτύξει
πηρινι κάναείναι τόσομ απλο υπάρχει θέμα της γραμμής όμως την ίδιαν ώρα να έμπρεπει να
νιώθουμε ότι αναγιά μου είμαι με τούτος είμαι με τους άλιος είμαιμε τος αμερικάνους είμαι
με τους ειρανούς είμαι με τοένακθιό χώρες και εμείς σιλαούς οποιζούν τις επιδράσεις όποιου δήποτ
πολέμου όποιου δήποτε πολέμα δεδηλαδή ι ανθρώποι που ζούσ το ιρά ελιγότερο ανθρώποι που μας
αν υπάρχουν του εσοι πολιτικές δτιαφορές και πρέπει να σταματήσει το πρόγραμμα το ιρά πρέπει
να γίνει με τρόπον πουν να σταματήςει αν τώρα ένας για τις όπως το σοπριν
λίτερ το το ιράν οδηγή έναν ολόκλο λαών σε μια κατάσταση την οποία επιδιόκοντας πολιτικά
φονταμεταριστικές ιδες οδηγήσει ένα ολοκλο λαός στην καταστροφή έναι αάάφυγε και διάδοχους πτω σητολοφωνία